alors je c'est pas qu'on est qu'il faut
être contre les informations quand il
arrivve des catastrophes climatiques on
va pas dire je ferme les yeux je veux
pas le savoir alors évidemment les
chaînes d'information c'est un peu trop
récurrent et et spectaculaire mais le
fait est que il y a les deux niveaux il
faut s'informer mais pas être inondé
donc clairement les conseils qu'on donne
qu'on donne à niveau préventif là c'est
des moments de déconnexion par exemple
on voit beaucoup de de vrais
professionnels du climat ceux qui sont
chercheurs ceux qui sont dans
climatologue NOTAM
ils sont inondés ça en général parce
queils ont une fibre personnelle le jour
et la nuit enfin c'est leur c'est leur
engagement et donc dans ce cas-là on va
pas leur dire mais laissez tomber ça n'a
aucune importance on va juste essayer de
leur dire comme on fait avec toute
gestion du stress faites des pauses
prenez le temps de respirer parce queil
faut vous préserver vous aussi donc
c'est ça la démarche vraiment et et les
professionnels peuvent accompagner ça si
possible le plutôt possible avant que ça
décompense et quand c'est décompensé B
on a nos outils